you know you know what i was thinking
let me let me let me let me pull this up
right here this other story
would you give up having children to
save the planet meet the couples who
have wow okay well you know i was
thinking it's like it's really funny
that the people who believe the world is
overpopulated are the same people who
believe that you should sterilize your
kids you should not have kids you should
abort your kids you should gorge
yourself until you're on the verge of
death because you can be healthy at any
size and i'm just like
isn't it weird that all of these weird
social things they advocate for just
result in less people
or is it just like
that's what they want well also i'm
gonna be honest and i don't know these
people but when i hear this it generally
strikes me as a post-hoc rationalization
i think people choose not to have
children for lifestyle reasons and then
they'll say something like it's for the
environment because they want to feel
good about themselves i don't think i
don't really know anyone who like really
really wanted to have kids but when i
can't it's for mother earth most people
i know who say that probably weren't
going to have kids i don't have many
kids anyway i think the issue is these
these young millennial women who aren't
having kids are are femme cells
you know
fem female incels or whatever i mean i
guess ensel works for women as well as
it does for men and i think they justify
it by saying they're they're choosing
this lifestyle it's like sour grapes
it's like well i don't want to have a
kid anyway it's like maybe just didn't
work out for you so you're you retreat
to the defensive position of well i
didn't want it so yeah i don't know
because i also know some like attractive
married millennials that are not having
kids like and just have no desire to do
it you know well for sure i'm not saying
that every instance of a woman not
having kids is
wrapped and so no i think that there are
probably many millennial women who it
didn't work out for and then claim it
was yeah
with this not having kids to save the
planet narrative is that you might
choose not to have a kid unfortunately
but you would have been a phenomenal
parent and that kid could have grown up
and made groundbreaking technology that
could have made the world so much better
and then you could be a terrible parent
that has 10 kids or one kid that ends up
being a deviant and a hostile individual
so
it really doesn't matter how many it
matters the quality
how many does matter but not as much as
the quality of what exists yeah but you
if you have like 50 babies you're bound
to have one good one right
odds are i guess it's an interesting
point about the like it's almost like a
rationalization that you're talking
about you know where if suppose that you
you know didn't want to have kids
because you didn't want to um
give up that much of yourself and of
your time and you know then you would
think like okay well does that make me
selfish and then you would invert it by
saying no no i'm not selfish at all i'm
actually doing the world a big favor you
know
i'm just actually you know being so
nurturing here of the world by not
having kids you know so i i don't know i
mean unfortunately i think that that may
be true for some of them but i honestly
think it's unfortunately that there
actually might genuinely be women that
would normally have just wanted to have
kids but they just can get brainwashed
by the idea that you know the world is a
terrible place or you know that that the
world cannot support those children and
that makes me really sad well let's take
it to the dark place i suppose if you
advocate for abortion you're less likely
to have offspring if you sterilize your
kids you're less likely to have your
genes persist beyond them if you gorge
yourself and you're very very unhealthy
you're also less likely to have kids
you're going to be
unhealthy and your genes will be removed
from the future future gene pool i went
through from age 28 to 38 to 24 i'm not
having i'm not bringing a kid into this
hell hole this earth that's just falling
apart no no way and it was i started off
saying it almost like a joke and then i
immediately started believing it i
noticed people around me started saying
it and only in the last three or four
years have i regained a will to live in
a kind of a
having faith that
we can make it better as hard as it is
and as dangerous and as destructive as
things can be we can make it better and
so i'm much more open to the idea yeah
no that's a very good point because i
think it says a lot about the state of a
person
based on what they believe it says a lot
less about the world and a lot more
about the person yes i'd given up on
reality yeah black pill i i got way too
much information on the internet in 2006
about
the military industrial complex monsanto
the pharmaceutical companies all the the
lies the media lies and i was like well
i mean how could we ever dig out of this
we're buried you know for for me i
actually uh
i felt similar that you can't have kids
because the the the climate and
everything was bad until i got on the
internet and started uh diving into the
deep rabbit holes of youtube and then i
realized because the earth is flat and
actually on the back of a turtle all the
climate change stuff doesn't matter
i like totals
17 i actually i actually begged a doctor
to give me a hysterectomy when i was
whoa i've heard a number of people say
similar things i i would love to hear
why you did it i did it because i was
convinced that i never wanted to have
you know children i was just like i
don't want to have to mess with birth
control my whole life like just give me
a hysterectomy and i am so thankful that
the doctor refused so i didn't want to
hysterectomy but i wanted my tubes tied
when i was like 20. and the doctor was
like you are too young and i was like
you're insane i know exactly what i want
what are you talking about and now of
course i'm like oh i'm 30. holy crap i
would really like to have kids let's go
thank goodness that that doctor didn't
enable me and now i look at these
doctors giving like you know puberty
blockers because i'm like holy crap i
know so bad it's bad they're just like
you're too young i was like yeah you
know what i was i had five siblings and
i was like i feel like i've raised
enough kids for my life i'm good on that
one but now i'm like yeah i feel like
it's really important and these hard
times are going to make strong people
well so so what changed for you you know
i mean i was only 17. you know what i
mean so i i think you know what what
changed is i mean my my executive lobe
matured right you know like which you
know doesn't have you're the executive
loop of your brain like which doesn't
finish growing until you're like 25 you
know i was also in a very difficult
place in my life i i had a kind of a
crazy childhood and everything i just
don't think i had a good template in my
mind you know for for what that would
look like and then you know just through
maturing and discovering that i could
have good relationships and that seeing
happy families and realizing that family
life could be a lot of fun it it wasn't
that big of a leap for me to be like ah
yes motherhood
it's it's wonderful that the doctor was
actually concerned with you and your
long-term interests rather than simply
validating the choice you said you
wanted to make at the time i think it's
very sad that as a society
affirmative care exactly we put so much
emphasis on what a person says that they
want in any particular moment that we
don't even stop to think about their
long-term well-being and also if someone
at 17 says i never ever want to have
children not because i want to do x y z
or i don't think i'm called to marriage
but i just don't want to bring life into
this world i think that's serious cause
for concern for someone to say like hey
what's going on like why do you feel
that way a person is revealing that that
there's as you mentioned some kind of
difficulty there that you were
struggling with and a person should care
when they hear that and want to help
intervene to lift the person not give
them surgeries take a look at this
opening paragraph from this article they
say gwen mckellen was 26 when she
decided to get sterilized
it took the recycling consultant five
years to find the appropriate doctor
under the public health plan she was on
but she was determined you know my only
response is if you are predisposed to
sterilizing yourself well then it's a
self-solving problem for everyone else
right i'm not saying to be mean it's
like if you don't want to have kids your
ideas die with you but here's the thing
i mean even people with bad ideas can
have good children and we are literally
below replacement right now so it's
actually bad for all of us okay seamus
have four kids i think i'm going to
that's one of the best yeah
i want look i want to have as many as
possible once i'm married yeah i think
look if
we're i'm talking about i'm like i'm i'm
thinking about that one woman i think
i'm married to one so this is
interesting
you know irish twins are no yes
yes no absolutely i i very much know
what irish you know what i heard i want
to double check on this um feel free to
fact check this but i heard that part of
why it it's generally the the stereotype
that irish people have many children
it's not just because you know we're
irish catholics it's because
women are they're less likely to
conceive when they're breastfeeding but
for whatever reason irish women tend to
be more likely to have a mutation where
they still will conceive even while they
are breastfeeding which is why you have
irish twins and irish triplets and irish
babies who are born one after another
so for those that aren't familiar irish
twins is basically when the woman gets
conceives and gets pregnant almost
immediately after she gives birth so you
actually have siblings who are not a
year older than each other yeah i was 13
months younger than my older sister so
my parents were not messing around not
quite irish not quite very close yeah
very close but it's like you'll have two
kids and they're they're like how old
are you i'm 10 and you 10 oh you're
twins well we're nine months 10 months
apart it's like oh interesting not a
year apart are there is there data
explaining why no this is this is also
why i said fact this is something i
heard recently that i found interesting
and that's why i'm issuing the caveat to
fact check this i just thought it was a
very interesting theory you know we
should do because it is a phenomenon
right like would people constantly say
well when you breastfeed you will not
get pregnant but i know i actually know
a number of like women who do have irish
twins who are like it's fascinating and
that we call them irish twins i find
that really interesting we should do
exponential tax credits uh child tax
credits yeah like so like the first kid
is as x the second kid is x plus y the
third you know third k is x plus y e
squared or whatever the priceline did
that
all right
hungry hungry the problem is having kids
that you don't take care of just for
money because it's not for money it's a
tax credit you're not getting money
you're paying less in taxes but like a
bad parent or one that's vague but like
a parent that's that's vacant that's off
working and has like five kids and they
don't instruct them on what's good and
then the kids grow up and become
villains you know that's a problem i
don't want to encourage that but we're
not giving you money it's a tax credit
so you're keeping more of the money you
earn i just don't know if more is better
it it's the quality of of the unit if
you have more than one child you need
that money you need a tax credit you
need to keep more of the money that you
earn in fact they know that one of the
problems that children face when they're
in a large family is that their parents
aren't able to earn quite as much this
is one of the reasons i wrote about this
this is why dementia is higher in
parents who have more than three
children because it's much more
stressful to be able to work enough to
give for example six children like we're
in my family to be able to give them a
stable home and i still to this day
don't understand how i was a single my
family was a single income home my
mother was a stay-at-home mother and i
had five siblings it's incredible to me
like you cannot duplicate that in this
day and age you guys did a lot of
sustainability right at the house no no
we did have five acres and we had cows
and chickens and goats and stuff but we
weren't like a green family we just um
were like culturally sound we went to
church we followed traditional values we
were homeschooled and my mother stayed
at home was very interesting
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you